Hey guys, how's it going
So apparently you all really liked that last insights video
It got a really good response and it did really well
So thanks for clicking on the like button and all that stuff
I figured, let's do one more, why not
Whenever I finish a video, I have all these facts and insights left over
That couldn't quite fit into it, so it feels good to give them a little home here.
We start in the chalice dungeons this time
There's some really weird stuff down here, especially in the deepest depths
How many of you have seen this thing before?
It's listed as a "labyrinth mole" in the wiki
And, statistically, it has to be the rarest creature you can find in Bloodborne
It's not even listed in the official guide, that's how rare it is.
It spits poisonous goop at you,  it slaps you around with its tentacles,
It can move its head to either sides of its body,
And well, obviously it has a grab attack.
and I'm not surprised my character went a little bit insane from that one.
Anyway, in the description below I've sourced its discovery
and you can come and gawk at it if you want.
And it's funny, people come to this chalice dungeon
like they would go to look at an animal in a zoo.
When I was walking up to it, there were all manner of messages like:
"Have audience with secret," or "Despicable blobby thing ahead"
Everyone just comes here to look at this thing, but don't kill it. "Treat blobby thing with care."
See if you can find my message here.
And, did you know, speaking of messages
Good segue, did you know that if you rate messages as "fine" or "foul"
Then the messengers will react.
They do a little dance when you rate it as fine,
and they cry when you rate it foul.
Sometimes, when you go down a significant path in a Chalice Dungeon or in the Nighmare Realm
You might catch these little blue lantern guys in the corner
They're actually little proximity sensors that light their lantern so you know that you've been through here before
They're a little method to stop you getting lost that I discovered about a week ago, so.
Really useful. Another thing you might have noticed on your Chalice Dungeon adventures
are the knights wearing plate.
Since there are no plate-wearing knights in Bloodborne's overworld,
It makes you wonder what era these knights were from.
In my headcanon, maybe the first forays down into the Chalice Dungeons
were from a time long ago when plate was still popular.
And then, finally, when they discovered what they were up against,
The more experienced forays down into the Chalice Dungeons would have had
The lightweight attire that Gehrman used as a hunter, hunting the beasts,
because it says in his item description that he popularized it.
Go through enough rooms, and eventually you'll find one with a giant bell in it
And of course, you're going to ring this thing, right?
You have to, how could you not?
It's a mistake. When you do, what seems like every enemy in the bloody chalice dungeon will come
to find you and murder you.
One of the most interesting things with this bell is that you can actually use the music box item
anywhere near the bell, and the bell will resonate as if it was hit.
I've been trying this music box on everything lately
Eldritch, super hidden meanings aside, I guess what's happening here is the bell is set
as an inter-actable element of the world, and that the music box checks everything in its vicinity
to elicit a response from it and I guess that triggers the bell
And that's exactly what makes the music box interesting
It actually has more effects than you would have first thought.
Everyone knows that Gascoigne reacts to the music box in the boss fight since it reminds him of his wife and daughters
But did you know that he also chuckles when you first play it near him
while he's summoned?
The song itself is the first few notes of "Mergo's Lullaby"
which plays during the Wet Nurse fight.
What's sort of interesting is that sometimes, if you spam this music box in this fight
it gets the boss caught in this endless cycle of side-stepping,
Which is really curious. I read about this on the wiki and I had to give it a go.
Maybe it's reacting to the tune? So far as I know it's the only creature that does this sometimes
I do wonder if it's a bug, though, similar to with the giant bell.
The idea that NPCs react to things that you do, other than attacks and talking,
Is something I hope they put into future games.
Take the doll, for example. A lot of you probably realized
that she reponds to gestures, there's no great discovery here
She'll clap with you when you're excited, she bows back at you, and she tilts her head quizically
When you do something weird, it's so endearing.
My favorite is when you do the "Make Contact" gesture
and this is the gesture that's used as some sort of communication with the great ones.
Wait a minute, and when your character switches sides, she all of a sudden decides to clap.
Maybe she's impressed that you can do it correctly.
And it turns out doing it correctly matters.
If you "Make Contact" with the Brain of Mensis until your arms switch sides
then you get the fully upgraded moon rune, which is the one that gives you more blood echoes.
And this is the rune that also mentions that the great ones are sympathetic in spirit
which is appropriate. The Nightmare of Mensis building
is one of those places that's able to be seen from
the Nightmare Frontier. And I love little details like these.
It makes you feel a little bit like you're exploring a real world.
Bloodborne does it fairly convincingly.
Other areas I've noticed are that Castle Cainhurst can be seen from Hemwick Charnel Lane
and you can also see the observatory at Byrgenwerth from the Forbidden Forest.
Are there any I'm missing? You can let me know in the comments. I probably am missing some.
The tenth little insight is to do with the beast roar.
Just like all the force spells in previous games,
Beast Roar deflects projectiles.
Whether it be giant boulders, fireballs, bullets, you name it. Just roar them away.
Number eleven: did you know that there's a hidden exit when you're riding up
the Cathedral Ward elevator? I didn't until recently.
It leads to the top floor of the Cathedral Ward, which houses the Formless Oedon rune and the urn costume
for the messengers. It also lets you do this.
Number 12 takes us to the abandoned hunter's workshop.
If you position yourself here, you hear something strange.
(female vocalizing)
It's the sound of an old woman laughing, repeating the same sound over and over again.
We've actually tracked down this sound to a door in an alleyway
in Cathedral Ward.
And it's a bizarre glitch, to say the least. It's so weird that a voice file would just start playing here,
and it's especially weird because this is a voice file that's located at the end
of one character's line of dialogue.
And it's not the full voice file. It's very strange.
But, sometimes in Bloodborne, things are in the game without too much purpose.
Take the Ring of Betrothal item for example.
You find it in the Pthumeru Ihyll root chalice dungeon
and you can use it to propose to Annalise, the Vileblood queen.
Even with all the hard work that you do for her, you still get rejected.
And it turns out you're doing some pretty gross stuff for her.
Annalise enlists hunters who go out and hunt other hunters so you can get their blood dregs
and feed them to your queen.
And she consumes these so that she can, and I quote, "One day bear a child of blood."
But have you ever looked closely at what the blood dregs are?
When you do, it makes sense why they might help her bear a "child of blood."
They're clearly meant to resemble sperm.
Maybe in the DLC there will be a use for that ring, but so far there's nothing that's been found.
Another item like this is the Yharnam Stone, which you get when you kill Queen Yharnam in the chalice dungeon.
It reads: "The queen lies dead, but her horrific consciousness is only asleep, and it stirs in unsettling motions."
The Yharnam Stone implies that the queen lives on, whether inside this stone
or in the Nightmare Realm, perhaps.
It reminds me entirely of Annalise, Queen of the Vilebloods.
Since she's the only other character who is immortal, and she's capable of living on
in a lump of flesh. And, make no mistake,
there are actually a lot of connections between these two characters.
I was really excited about this when I discovered it around the time I was doing
the Cainhurst lore video, uh, but none of this information really fit in that video
because it does take a while to explain, but bear with me
Even the song that plays during Yharnam's boss fight
is titled "Queen of the Vilebloods" which is the same song that plays when you fight Logarius
who guards the actual queen of the Vilebloods.
So, let's list some of the connections. There are two undying queens,
who leave behind a bloody token of their immortality.
These are two queens that share the "Queen of the Vilebloods" soundtrack.
They're also two queens with strong connections to blood.
One of them started a line of followers who partook of her blood, that's Annalise,
and the other one wields a kind of blood sorcery when she fights.
Both of them are also related to the ring of betrothal, which is a ring found in Pthumeru Ihyll
which is also Queen Yharnam's chalice dungeon.
And the description of the ring clearly relates to Queen Yharnam.
And Queen Annalise is the only character who recognizes this ring as a wedding ring.
A wedding ring that says it's only permitted to those who are slated to bear a special child,
which is a phrase that applies to both queens.
So, I just rambled on quickly about their similarities,
But what does this mean? What are some of the consequences for Bloodborne's timeline,
for example. Well, Vileblood, as mentioned by Alfred,
was another strain of the old blood, stolen from Byrgenwerth long ago
by a scholar. And this was likely back when
the scholars were still exploring the tombs.
It makes you wonder: could Queen Yharnam be the source of this vileblood?
The thing that seals it for me is the fact that Queen Yharnam of the chalice dungeons has chains around her wrists
implying that she was perhaps found and restrained at some point
and maybe even exploited so that the blood could be taken from her.
And it could have got into the populace and eventually led to the rise of the Vileblood line.
Also, finally, when you hit Queen Yharnam, the baby Mergo screams out.
She's clearly had something ripped from her pregnant stomach, perhaps it was the umbilical cord
that granted Mensis audience with Mergo, the infant great one
at the top of the Nightmare of Mensis.
This would also explain Queen Yharnam's presence outside, after all. There are just so many
connections here, between Queen Yharnam and the outside world.
So I'm curious to see what you guys think.
Maybe we can take this a little bit further, even.
And I think this is all I can think of. I don't think I'll be able to scrape together
another 15 things that are high enough in quality to include, so
Thanks so much for supporting this series,
and I hope you stay tuned for more Bloodborne and Dark Souls III stuff in the future
And I'll see you in the next one. Cheers guys.